Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Well, what a week it has been. What a tournament. And our thoughts turn inevitably to the retrospective after a feast of prime ministerial sport. It has, of course, been the rest is history. Prime ministerial World Cup.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。好了，过去这一周真是精彩纷呈。这是一场多么精彩的赛事啊。在一场首相级的体育盛宴之后，我们的思绪不可避免地转向了回顾。这当然就是“历史的余烬”首相级世界杯。
And Tom Holland and I, Dominic Sambruch, we're still really in in shock i think from some of those results aren't we tom so much to talk about so many matches that i think will live long in the memory and i thought fascinating not just for the kind of individual matches but for the light that it shone on the whole field of prime ministerial sport the reputations are we going to do the whole podcast like this how are we going to um well the saints and grieves of history well well dominic okay well well that depends doesn't it dominic because that depends whether you think that organizing british prime ministers into uh a a fake world cup and then having people vote on them on twitter
我和汤姆·霍兰德——我是多米尼克·桑布鲁克——我觉得我们仍然对其中一些比赛结果感到非常震惊，对吧，汤姆？有太多的话题要聊，有那么多的比赛我想都会长久留在记忆中。我觉得它们不仅因为各自精彩的对局而引人入胜，更因为它们照亮了整个首相体育领域。这些声誉……难道我们要以这种方式做完整期播客吗？我们要怎么……嗯，历史上的圣徒与格雷夫斯们……好吧，好吧，多米尼克，好吧，那得看情况了，对吧，多米尼克？因为这取决于你是否认为把英国首相们组织成一个虚构的世界杯，然后让人们在推特上为他们投票
is the best way to evaluate their reputations. Do you think it is? Well, it's a way. Well, you're never comparing like with like, are you? I mean, you're never comparing like with like anyway. So I don't think it's, of course, it's a ludicrous exercise, but arguably it's no more ludicrous than all the other exercises that are done comparing, you know, it's a Robert Walpole and Clement Attlee or whatever.
这是评估他们声誉的最佳方式。你觉得是吗？嗯，这算是一种方式。好吧，你永远无法将同类进行比较，不是吗？我的意思是，无论如何你都无法进行同类比较。所以我不认为……当然，这是一个荒谬的游戏，但可以说它并不比其他所有进行比较的游戏更荒谬，你知道的，比如把罗伯特·沃波尔和克莱门特·艾德礼作比较之类的。
So, you know what? It was fun. I thought it was fun and it was revealing about a particular demographic, i.e. our listeners, and what they think of our prime ministerial history. So I did learn. I actually did learn from it. Didn't you? Okay.
所以，你知道吗？这很有趣。我觉得这很有趣，而且它反映了一个特定的群体，也就是我们的听众，以及他们对我们的首相历史的看法。所以我确实学到了东西。我真的从中有所收获。你没有吗？好吧。
Yeah, I did. And for the benefit of those who aren't on Twitter and aren't aware of what we're talking about, which may well be a sizable number of people who are listening to this, we organised a tournament, a kind of knockout tournament. So we had best of 16, quarterfinals, semifinals, final, to find out who the most popular British prime minister was, the prime minister that people who listen to this podcast and who follow it on Twitter chose as the greatest British prime minister. And Dominic, you selected the 16 prime ministers, didn't you? Yes. And you seeded them. So we had eight seeds who were, who were they? Churchill was top seed i think so it's churchill um walpole disraeli
是的，我也有。为了那些不上推特、不知道我们在谈论什么的人——这可能占了收听本期节目的听众中相当大的一部分——我们组织了一场锦标赛，一种淘汰赛。所以我们有16强赛、四分之一决赛、半决赛、决赛，以此来找出谁是最受欢迎的英国首相，也就是收听这个播客并在推特上关注它的人们所选出的最伟大的英国首相。多米尼克，你挑选了这16位首相，对吧？是的。而且你给他们排了种子序位。所以我们有八位种子选手，他们是谁？丘吉尔是头号种子，我想是的，所以是丘吉尔、沃波尔、迪斯雷利
gladstone pit the younger atlee lloyd george and thatcher right so they so they were the eight and then the other eight were and the other eight were lord salisbury um tony blair vican parmiston pit the elder so put the younger was seeded but put the elder not lord liverpool um hh asquith uh to robert peel and harold wilson who was inserted at the last minute at the producer's request because the producer thought there were insufficient labor names in the 16 and he wanted an extra person of course wilson got knocked out of the first hurdle so that proves what tony knows about history and since he's not here for this recording there's nothing he can do about him were there were there any uh prime ministers you felt were unlucky not to make that 16
格莱斯顿、小皮特、艾德礼、劳埃德·乔治和撒切尔，对吧？所以他们就是前八位，然后另外八位是……另外八位是索尔兹伯里勋爵、托尼·布莱尔、帕麦斯顿子爵、老皮特——所以小皮特是种子选手，但老皮特不是——利物浦勋爵、H·H·阿斯奎斯、罗伯特·皮尔爵士，以及在最后一分钟应制作人要求插进来的哈罗德·威尔逊，因为制作人觉得16人名单里的工党名字不够多，他想要一个额外的人选。当然，威尔逊在第一关就被淘汰了，这证明了托尼对历史的了解有多少。既然他没来参加这次录音，他也无可奈何。有没有哪位首相，你觉得没能进入这16强是很不走运的？
well i think i would have put stanley baldwin in, but that's probably because I'm a bit biased because I like Stanley Baldwin. I think when I look at our list and I look at the tournament, I think it's very modern heavy. So I think the 18th century looks like a huge black hole, doesn't it? And we didn't have anybody between. I mean, we had Pitt the Elder and Walpole. But, you know, there's all these names, sort of the Duke of Newcastle or something, the Earl of Bute. But basically nobody knows anything about. And we didn't, you know, there's a big hole.
嗯，我想我会把斯坦利·鲍德温放进去，但这可能是因为我有点偏心，因为我喜欢斯坦利·鲍德温。我觉得当我审视我们的名单和这场锦标赛时，我发现它带有太重的现代色彩。所以我觉得18世纪看起来像是一个巨大的黑洞，对吧？而且我们中间没有任何人。我的意思是，我们有老皮特和沃波尔。但是，你知道，有所有这些名字，比如纽卡斯尔公爵之类的人，比特伯爵。但基本上没有人知道他们是谁。而且我们并没有，你知道的，这是一个巨大的空缺。
It's like the lists of kind of 100 great albums, isn't it? And it's always the most recent albums that kind of pop up. Yes, exactly. Exactly right. With possibly Sgt Pepper lurking around at number three or something. Although, although, Tom, my expectation, which was Thatcher and Blair would do very well for precisely that reason, as they do well in polls nationally, was not borne out. And I think that's an interesting example of the difference between political enthusiasts or history enthusiasts and the general public.
这就像那种“100张伟大专辑”的榜单一样，对吧？而且总是那些最新的专辑会冒出来。是的，完全正确。完全正确。可能还会有《佩珀军士》潜伏在第三位左右。不过，不过，汤姆，我的预期是撒切尔和布莱尔会表现得非常好，正是出于这个原因，就像他们在全国民调中表现得很好一样，但这并没有得到证实。我认为这是一个有趣的例子，说明了政治狂热分子或历史狂热分子与普通大众之间的区别。
Because while we were doing this, I was moved to look up the most recent survey. Have you seen this? The most recent national poll done by YouGov in 2019, where they asked people who was the best prime minister. Now, who do you think people chose? The majority of the population. Churchill. Churchill. 21%, I think, chose Churchill.
因为在我们做这件事的时候，我心血来潮去查了最近的一次民意调查。你见过这个吗？这是YouGov在2019年进行的最近一次全国民调，他们询问人们谁是最佳首相。现在，你认为人们选了谁？占人口大多数的人。丘吉尔。丘吉尔。我想有21%的人选择了丘吉尔。
Number two? I've no idea. I don't know. Thatcher, 19%. And then everybody else, I mean, literally everybody else was nowhere. Everybody else was kind of 4%, 5%. I think Tony Blair was 5%. Atlee was 4% or something like that.
第二名呢？我不知道。我不知道。撒切尔，19%。然后其他人，我的意思是，字面意义上的其他人都不行。其他人大概占4%、5%左右。我想托尼·布莱尔是5%。艾德礼是4%或者差不多的数字。
And, you know, everything. And that just shows how there's a difference between the public and our listeners actually or are you perhaps implying that people on left wing are people on twitter are more left wing than people who aren't well that's a shocking thought that's been yeah i mean that will horrify some of our listeners perhaps but of course that's well chronicled isn't it that twitter tends to to skew to the left and i think you saw that a little bit in this in our exercise okay so so it's a bit like england playing in mexico that it's it's it's harder for certain players to compete on twitter i think there are there are definitely one or two players i can think of one
而且，你知道，这一切。这恰恰表明了公众和我们的听众之间存在差异，或者你是在暗示左翼人士或推特上的人比那些不上推特的人更偏向左翼吗？嗯，这是一个令人震惊的想法，确实是这样，我的意思是，这可能会吓到我们的一些听众，但当然，这是有据可查的，不是吗？推特往往倾向于左翼，我想你在我们的这个活动中也多多少少看到了这一点。好吧，所以这有点像英格兰队在墨西哥踢球，某些球员在推特上竞争会更困难。我想绝对有一两个球员——我能想到一个球员，特别是有一个球员，我觉得……我不认为……如果你把玛格丽特·撒切尔放在推特民调中与任何人对决，无论是动物、植物还是矿物，她都会输。简·林、博诺·劳、诺斯勋爵。好吧。那么，我们要不要看看小组赛，然后直接……本质上，我们不讨论比赛的细节。我们只谈论竞争者以及他们的状态如何。当然。第一轮是迪斯雷利对阵索尔兹伯里勋爵。迪斯雷利赢了。他获得了79%的选票。所以对于迪斯雷利，我们在这一点上有点分歧，因为我想把他作为种子选手，而你不想。我想这是你在我面前作出的唯一妥协，就是让迪斯雷利进入了名单。好吧，在这里你看到了一个非常好的例子，我认为，汤姆，那就是
player in particular i think i don't think i think if you put margaret thatcher on a twitter poll against anybody animal vegetable or mineral, she's going to lose. Jane Lynn, Bono Law, Lord North. Okay. Well, should we look at the group matches and just do it to – essentially, we're not going to discuss the ins and outs of the match. We're just going to talk about the contenders and how they shape up. Sure. The first round was Disraeli against Lord Salisbury. And Disraeli won that. He got 79% of the vote. So Disraeli, we had a bit of a difference on that because I wanted him as a seed and you didn't. And I think that was the only thing that you seeded to me was letting Disraeli get in. Well, here you've got a really good example, I think, Tom, of the
我们看待历史上的首相的方式。所以，我的意思是，我们做过无数期播客，讨论过历史上的伟人或伟大以及个人。但首相是一个有趣的话题，因为历史记录、历史学家对他们的看法以及他们在公众记忆中的地位之间，总是存在细微的差别。所以对于迪斯雷利，我认为有一个巨大的差异，你知道的——他担任首相的时间并没有那么长，嗯，他……你知道的，他在当时绝没有那么惊人的受欢迎，但他却在人们的想象中留下了如此巨大的印记，作为一个某种维多利亚时代的首相，你知道的，作为一个花花公子，作为帝国主义的面孔，作为民粹主义保守主义的面孔，维多利亚女王爱他，维多利亚女王爱他，还有格莱斯顿
way we think about prime ministers in history. So, I mean, we've done tons of podcasts where we've talked about great men or greatness and individuals in history. But prime ministers are an interesting one because there's always a slight difference between, you know, the historical record and what historians think of them and their place in the public memory so disraeli i think there is a there is a big difference between you know he wasn't prime minister that long um he you know he wasn't as astoundingly popular at the time by any means but he's left this enormous imprint on the popular imagination as a sort of victorian prime minister you know it's a sort of dandy as the face of imperialism it's the face of kind of populatourism and queen victoria loved him and queen victoria loved him and the sort of gladstone
与迪斯雷利的争夺战，迪斯雷利总是被提起，你知道的，我们在电影里看到他，某种安东尼·谢尔总是在关于维多利亚女王的电影里扮演他，这一切都非常欢乐，每个人看到他都很高兴，你知道的，这就是迪斯雷利。但索尔兹伯里勋爵是一个重要得多的人物。他担任首相的时间更长。他主持了……你知道的，如果你要挑一个英国真正成为头号大国的时刻，我想在索尔兹伯里勋爵统治下可能就是那个时刻。索尔兹伯里勋爵典型地代表了一种特定的保守主义
disraeli rivalry and disraeli props up and you know we see him in films sort of somebody anthony scher is always playing him in films about queen victoria and it's all very jolly and everybody's pleased to see him you know there's disraeli But Lord Salisbury was a much more substantial figure. He was Prime Minister for longer. He presided over, you know, if you're going to pick a moment when Britain really was top nation, I think under Lord Salisbury it would probably be it. And Lord Salisbury epitomised a particular kind of Toryism
非常成功，也就是19世纪末的别墅保守主义。所以关于索尔兹伯里勋爵，他三次担任首相，对吧？是的。而且当19世纪变成20世纪时，他是首相。确实如此，是的。他说过我最喜欢的关于首相的名言，那就是：无论发生什么，都会变得更糟，
that's very successful, kind of Villa Toryism at the end of the 19th century. So the thing about Lord Salisbury, who is Prime Minister three times, isn't he? Yeah. And he's Prime Minister when the 19th century becomes the 20th century. Exactly he is, yes. He said my favourite ever Prime Ministerial saying, which is whatever happens will be for the worse,
因此，让尽可能少的事情发生才最符合我们的利益。我想，那些不喜欢保守派的人会认为这正是保守主义的精髓，就是阻止任何事情改变。但那并不是他所做的，对吧？我的意思是，因为基本上索尔兹伯里勋爵确实为20世纪保守党的形式奠定了基础，而事实上，在20世纪，保守党的形式比自由党或工党都要成功得多。在20世纪的保守党形态，事实上，这比20世纪的自由党或工党都要成功得多。是的，所以索尔兹伯里
and therefore it is in our interest that as little should happen as possible. And I guess that that's the people who don't like conservatives think that that's the essence of conservatism, just stop anything changing. But that's not what he did, is it? I mean, because basically Lord Salisbury does lay the foundations for the kind of 20th century incarnation of the Conservative Party, which actually has been much more successful than either the Liberals or Labour in the 20th century incarnation of the Conservative Party which actually has been much more successful than either the Liberals or Labour in the 20th century. Yes, so Salisbury
没错，索尔兹伯里说过很多反动的话，他看起来非常反动，他某种程度上体现了……他似乎体现了这一点。他看起来很反动是因为他有一把大胡子。是的。是的，基本上我想说的就是这个。尽管如果科尔宾当选首相，那么他就会……他的胡子更短一些，我想，没有人能反驳这一点。我知道我在说什么。如果科尔宾当选首相，那么他就会……他的胡子更短。
exactly, Salisbury said a lot of reactionary things, he looked very reactionary he kind of incarnated he seemed to incarnate. And he looked reactionary because he had a big beard. Yes. Yeah, basically that's what I'm saying. Although had Corbyn become Prime Minister then he would have been His beard was smaller, I think, no one can dispute that. I know saying. If Corbyn had become Prime Minister, then he would have been... His beard was smaller.
我认为没有人能反驳科尔宾……我知道，但自索尔兹伯里勋爵以来，我们还没有过留胡子的首相。所以科尔宾未能成为首相，在美髯公阵线（pogonophile front）上真是一个白白错失的机会。索尔兹伯里也是第一位使用电力的首相。所以他的房子里完全装满了电灯，远远领先于几乎，你知道的，他的大多数同龄人。当你说是他的房子时……嗯，他的庄园……是的，太庞大了。但是，索尔兹伯里，我的意思是——为索尔兹伯里勋爵辩护显然是荒谬的，因为他在公众舆论方面已经“死”了。
I think no one can dispute that Corbyn... I know, but we've had no bearded Prime Minister since Lord Salisbury. So Corbyn not becoming Prime Minister was a wasted opportunity on the Pogonophile front. Salisbury's also the first Prime Minister to have electricity. So he's got his house fully kitted out with electric lights, well ahead of almost, you know, most of his contemporaries. And when you say his house... Well, hisal yeah it's colossal but but salisbury well i mean there's it's obviously ludicrous to make a case for lord salisbury because he's he's dead in terms of public opinion
除了历史学家和历史爱好者之外，没有人真正记得索尔兹伯里勋爵，但我认为他其实是一个比迪斯雷利重要得多的人物。但我想这恰恰指出了一点，人们在这次评选中投票的一部分原因，不仅是政治成就，还有他们在历史想象中留下的那种——那种冲击力。没错，迪斯雷利是个妙语连珠的人，他是个小说家，他很华丽，他是格莱斯顿式维多利亚道德主义的对照物。他有点像狄更斯，对吧？他成了首相。是的，他是狄更斯和劳埃德·乔治之间的中转站。所以，你知道，这就是……而且迪斯雷利也是第一位……所以英国有一个巨大的传统，我想，那就是江湖骗子式首相的传统——我们现在就有一个，所以，你知道
nobody really remembers lord salisbury other than historians and historical enthusiasts but he's a much more substantial figure i would argue really than disraeli but i guess that that kind of points out that part of what people are voting for in this is it's not just political achievements it's the kind of the the the the charge that you leave in the historical imagination exactly disraeli is a wit he's a novelist he's flamboyant and he's a contrast to gladstonian victorian moralism um he's kind of dickens isn't he and he's become prime minister yeah he's he's the he's the way station between dickens and lloyd george so you know that's and he also disraeli is the first so there's a huge tradition in britain i think of the mountebank prime minister um and we have one now so you know
英国的英国选民非常喜欢一个江湖骗子，我想“江湖骗子”这个词就是这么来的，迪斯雷利是个江湖骗子，劳埃德·乔治是个江湖骗子，托尼·布莱尔有点像个江湖骗子，鲍里斯·约翰逊绝对是个江湖骗子，确实是的，对吧。不过，我的意思是，我认为这作为一个提醒挺有意思的，即人们在历史记录中留下的印象，已经超出了专业历史学家研究的学术文本的范畴。绝对的。我的意思是，你从罗马皇帝身上也能看到这一点，对吧，汤姆？是的，这是其中至关重要的一部分。是的，是的。好吧，我们已经谈了迪斯雷利。
the british the british vote electorate loves a mountebank i think mountebank is the word and the israeli was a mountebank lloyd george was a mountebank tony blair was a bit of a mountebank and boris johnson is a mountebank definitely is yeah okay but i mean i think that that this is kind of interesting as a reminder that the impression that people leave on the historical record is it extends beyond the academic texts that professional historians study. Absolutely. I mean, you get this from the Roman emperors, don't you, Tom? Yeah, and that's a crucial part of it. Yeah, yeah. Well, we've talked about Disraeli.
不可避免地，我们现在来到格莱斯顿，他——被非常有趣地抽签对阵托尼·布莱尔，而格莱斯顿赢了，他得到了55%的选票，所以那实际上是一场相当艰难的战斗。在我们专门谈论格莱斯顿之前，我想也许我们应该把格莱斯顿稍微留到后面一点，因为他在比赛的后期成了一个大明星，对吧？好吧，那我们来谈谈托尼·布莱尔。我认为布莱尔的黯然退场是如此有趣，而且我认为布莱尔在推特上显然将面临一场极其艰难的苦战，因为正如你所说，推特倾向于左翼，而布莱尔则因伊拉克问题而受到重创。但我认为，作为一个首相人物，托尼·布莱尔最迷人的地方在于，他赢得了三次大选，他显然非常受欢迎，作为一名选举获胜者也非常有效，
Inevitably, we now come on to Gladstone who um was drawn very amusingly against tony blair um and gladstone got he won 55 so that was that was quite a tough battle actually before we talk about gladstone specifically i think maybe we should leave gladstone slightly later on because he's becomes a big star later in the tournament doesn't he okay so let's talk about tony blair it's blair bowing out that i think is so interesting and I think Blair clearly Blair on Twitter is always going to face a big uphill battle because as you say Twitter kind of leans to the left and Blair is crippled by Iraq but I think what's fascinating about Tony Blair as a prime ministerial character is he won three elections he was obviously tremendously popular and tremendously effective as an electoral
但我数不出有哪位首相在离任后声誉会如此急剧地下跌。你知道的，所以托尼·布莱尔现在是这样一位首相：基本上，你知道的，他在公众面前露面，去街角小店买牛奶，人们就会因为伊拉克问题对他大喊大叫，说，哦，你逃去了美国，或者你是个骗子之类的话。好吧，但这难道不是同样至关重要的吗？他不会去街角小店买牛奶，因为他太有钱了，而这也是其中的另一个方面。嗯，我想是的，我的意思是——但首相们离任时往往很有富有，我的意思是玛格丽特·撒切尔，你通过演讲赚了很多钱，但你会指望她这么做，因为她——你知道的，她的一切都与赚钱有关，我的意思是，那就是她的全部意义所在。而托尼·布莱尔——我的意思是，他本应是一个社会主义者，而他却只是聚敛财富，人们从来不喜欢社会主义者赚钱，我想是的。而且我想——我只是觉得他是一个非凡的——你知道，总有一天会有人写出托尼·布莱尔的非凡传记，这看起来就像是一场希腊悲剧，从1997年“一切只会更好”（things can only get better）的轨迹——人们在唐宁街10号外挥舞着小小的联合杰克旗，到现在的这种感觉——实际上对很多人来说，他甚至变成了一个喜剧人物，嗯——对我来说不是，多米尼克。好吧，我知道你一直是……我只需听他说话，然后我就会想，是的，这完全是……什么好见解。但你看，你钦佩他是出于所有错误的原因，不是吗？我认为他正是那个幕后推手，提出第一剂疫苗、第二剂疫苗应该推迟接种，然后这个想法被政府采纳，并成为了……他是一手促成了这一点。你觉得呢，汤姆？我认为，我的意思是，我认为他正是那个极力推动这一点的政治人物，后来被采纳了。所以我想他仍然——无论如何，他还在外面做好事。嗯，布莱尔被淘汰了——好吧，让它过去吧，随它去吧。这就引发了随后的四分之一决赛中迪斯雷利和格莱斯顿之间那场引人入胜的对决。我的意思是，绝对是一场属于球迷的比赛，这正是锦标赛所想要、所需要也得到了的。所以我们会在适当的时候谈到这一点，但接下来的——接下来的小组赛是温斯顿·丘吉尔，头号种子——所以我们也许稍后会谈到丘吉尔。他以62%的得票率战胜了帕麦斯顿子爵。
vote winner but I can't think of many prime ministers whose reputation has sunk so precipitously after leaving office. You know, so Tony Blair is now the one prime minister who basically, you know, he shows his face in public, he goes to buy some milk at the corner shop and people shout at him about Iraq and say, oh, you ran off to America or you're a fraud and all that sort of thing. Well, but isn't it also crucial he wouldn't go and buy milk from a corner shop because he's so rich and that's another aspect of it well i suppose so i mean but prime ministers are often rich when they leave office i mean margaret thatcher you made a lot of money from speeches but you'd expect her to because she's she you know she was all about
我认为我最喜欢的维多利亚时代首相——所以他是首相，1855年至1858年，1859年至1865年。他是个了不起的小伙子，对吧？我认为是的。我认为帕麦斯顿会——我很惊讶他没有被完全取消资格，这说明他的知名度还不够高。因为在“我也是”（Me Too）的时代，我不认为他是一个非常——你知道的，他不是。你不会为了——你知道的，你不会为帕麦斯顿子爵的名誉去拼命，对吧？他就是那种去维多利亚女王那里做客，却去打扰她、打扰她的女佣，你知道的，手脚不干净的人。
making money i mean that was that was what it was all about whereas tony blair was i mean he was supposedly a socialist and he just kind of made and people never like socialists making money i think no and i suppose i just think he it's an extraordinary you know one day somebody's an extraordinary biography of tony blair and it will seem like this sort of greek tragedy the trajectory from the 1997 things can only get better people waving their little union jacks outside number 10 to the sort of sense now that he's he's actually become for a lot of people i think almost a comic figure um not for me dominic well i know you were you were you i just have to listen to him and i
我的意思是，这是一回事。据推测，难道不是因为他走进房间时以为那是某个他一直——那是他通常会受到欢迎的卧室，结果发现……是的，我知道，这从今天的角度来看确实不太好。但他确实讲过一个史上最伟大的首相级笑话，对那个法国人说的，那个法国人说：“如果我不是法国人，我希望成为一个英国人。”对此，帕麦斯顿机智地回答道：“如果我不是英国人，我也希望成为一个英国人。”对此，帕麦斯顿机智地回答道：“如果我不是英国人，我也希望成为一个英国人。”当然，他是——对于帕麦斯顿，你再次看到了历史记录与公众形象之间的微小差距。就帕麦斯顿拥有公众形象而言，它就是那种披荆斩棘、虽然年事已高却依然勇猛的炮舰外交的代言人。
think yeah that's completely what's good what good sense but you see you admire him for all the wrong reasons though don't you i think he was the person who was behind the idea that the um that the first vaccine the second vaccine should be delayed which then got picked up by the government and became he he was single-handedly single-handedly responsible for that you think tom i think i mean i think he was he was the political figure who was pushing for that the hardest and then got taken up so i think he's still he's still out there doing good anyway um blair got knocked out um yeah leave it up let it go and that set up that then set up the intriguing quarterfinal round between disraeli and gladstone i mean absolutely one for the fans that's what the tournament wanted
因为他当上首相时已经70岁了。所以他是成为首相年龄最大的人。基本上，帕麦斯顿的作风——你知道的，诸如堂多米尼加事件以及所有这些事情——就是如果有人与英国有哪怕一丝一毫的联系，有最微弱的公民身份主张，而且——你知道的，他们的脸在某个跳蚤肆虐的港口的酒吧里挨了耳光，帕麦斯顿就会派一艘炮舰去把那个跳蚤轰成粉碎，展现英国强硬的手腕。
and needed and got so we'll come to that in due course but the next um the next group match was uh winston churchill top seed so we'll perhaps come on to churchill later he won by 62 against the viscount palmerston um i think my favorite victorian prime minister so he's prime minister um 1855 to 8 1859 to 65 he's a tremendous lad isn't he i think yes i think palmerston would i'm surprised he hasn't i guess it's a sign that he's not better known that he hasn't been totally cancelled. Because in the age of Me Too, I don't think he's a very, you know, he's not. You wouldn't go to, you know, you wouldn't dine a ditch for Viscount Palmerston's reputation, would you? He's the kind of guy who goes to stay with Queen Victoria and he bothers her, bothers her maids and, you know, can't keep his hands to himself.
是的，所以他某种程度上是19世纪中期维多利亚时代炮舰外交绝对自信的化身。所以他输了并不真的让人感到意外。不，我的意思是，这可能——这不是属于他的一年，我想我们可以安全地说，这不是他的时刻。好吧，说到华丽的帝国扩张，接下来的小组赛又是一场——我的意思是，这是一场经典的比赛，群众非常喜欢，这再次是他们想要的：小皮特对阵老皮特，也就是儿子对阵父亲。小皮特以75%的得票率获胜。多米尼克，所以——老皮特、小皮特，跟我们讲讲他们吧，因为人们可能对他们不太了解。好吧，所以老皮特是——
I mean, that's one thing. Supposedly, wasn't that because he went into the room thinking that it was someone who he'd been it was a usual bedroom who would welcome yes who i think there was some control i agree it's it doesn't look entirely good from from from today's perspective but he did make one of the all-time great prime ministerial jokes to the french guy who who said that if i were not a frenchman i would wish to be an englishman to which palmerston wittily replied if i were not an englishman i would wish to be an englishman to which palmerston wittily replied if i were not an englishman i would wish to be an englishman too but of course he is the palmerston again you got the the um the slight gap between the historical record and the public image and insofar as palmerston has a public image it is the swashbuckling
他成为了查塔姆伯爵，他是18世纪中后期的人。老皮特是——其实我对老皮特了解不多，汤姆。我本想虚张声势一番，然后我想我知道他的——特鲁姆普打印了一堆资料，他肯定是有备而来的，所以我还是让你来讲吧。好吧，老皮特——其实我当时挺支持他的，他是我最喜欢的人，是我希望获胜的人，因为他是老塞勒姆（Old Sarum）的国会议员，那个地方——我想他们大概只有五个选民和大约50只羊。
sort of aged but swashbuckling exponent of gumbo diplomacy. Because he's 70 when he becomes prime minister. So he's the oldest person to become prime minister. And basically, Palmerston's thing, you know, the sort of Don Pacifico affair and all these sort of, is that if somebody has even the slightest connection to Britain, the most tenuous claim to citizenship and, you know, their face is slapped in a bar in some sort of um fly bitten port palmerston will send a gunboat to blast to blast the fly and strong arm of england
而他统治了下议院。这就是你对羊的全部了解？仅此而已。不，因为他基本上——他不是作为首相，而是作为基本上促成英国在七年战争中取得成功的人。是的，是的，完全正确。我们的播客在适当的时候由丹·斯诺（Dan Snow）讲过关于七年战争的内容。他基本上是那个把英国变成全球帝国强权的人。所以，你同样可以说，今年或许不是属于他的一年。我记得有一句很棒的名言：“我知道唯有我能拯救这个国家，舍我其谁”或者类似的话。玛格丽特·撒切尔在她的回忆录中引用了这句话，说她当上首相时想到了老皮特。然后是小皮特——我的意思是，小皮特是为数不多的、我认为真正堪称巨擘的人物之一。所以我觉得皮特——你知道的，如果由我来挑选仅仅基于表现的半决赛选手，我认为小皮特会——正如他确实做的那样——成为一名半决赛选手，因为他在18世纪末登场。
yes so he's the he's the kind of the embodiment of um victorian gunboat absolutely self-confidence in the middle of the 19th century so it's not really surprising he lost um no i mean this was probably this is this wasn't his year i think we can safely say this this isn't this moment okay and and talking of of flamboyant imperial expansion the the next group ran again i mean this was a classic one for the i mean the crowds loved this is again what they wanted pit the younger against pit the elder so son against father uh pit the younger one that's 75 so dominic so so pit the elder pit the younger tell us about them because people may not know about them right so pit the elder is um
他当时是——他当上首相时多大？24岁。24岁。而且他拥有年轻的资本。所以我们有年龄最大的帕麦斯顿。是的。
he becomes lord chatham he is uh sort of mid to late 18th century um pit the elder is uh i don't actually know much about pit the elder tom i was going to try and bluff it and then i thought i know his trums printed out a load of stuff and he's got to come prepared so i'll let you do it well pit the elder i was actually backing he was my favorite he was the guy i wanted to win because he was um mp for old serum which was one of the right i think they had kind of five voters and about 50 sheep. And he dominated the House of Commons. Is that all you know about the sheep? That's all.
小皮特是最年轻的。皮特被视为反腐败的化身，在此之前英国政坛经历了一段相当腐败的时期，实际上可以追溯到沃波尔。他是现代的——他创建了一系列联盟来对抗拿破仑，他非常反雅各宾派、反法国大革命、充满爱国主义。是的，他确实如此，他是那个幕后推手——基本上激励英国在革命时期和拿破仑时期与法国战斗。在特拉法尔加战役和奥斯特利茨战役后不久去世，但他是一个非常坚定的废奴主义者。所以我觉得，是的，现在人们看待首相的一个非常重要的方面，就是他们在帝国和奴隶制问题上的立场。是的，因为这在推特评论中一次又一次地出现，不是吗？一次又一次，是的。
No, because he's basically, he's not as prime minister, but he's the guy who's essentially behind Britain's success in the Seven Years' War. Yes, yes, exactly. Our podcast was Dan Snow about the Seven Years' War in due course. the guy who's essentially behind britain's success in the seven years war yes yes exactly that's his dan snow about the seven years war in in due course but he essentially is is the guy who who makes britain a global imperial power so again you might well say that this year is not perhaps his year here's a great line i know that i alone can save the country and no one else can or something like that which margaret thatcher quotes in her memoirs saying she thought of pit the elder when she became prime minister and then pit the younger i mean pit the younger is one of
所以老皮特绝对是——我的意思是，他是“大英帝国先生”。而小皮特显然通过使英国免受法国入侵而将国家维系在一起。但在涉及奴隶制时，他绝对是站在天使这一边的。他是威伯福斯的友人，是废奴主义的坚定反对者。所以这或许可以解释为什么——这可能就是他能走得那么远的部分原因。
those few relatively few figures i think who is just a genuine colossus so i think pit the you know if you would if i was picking semi-finalists purely on performance i think pit the younger would have as indeed he was um would be a semi-finalist because he comes in at the end of the 18th century. He's, what is he, 24 when he becomes prime minister? 24. And he's got, so he's got young legs. So we've had Palmerston's the oldest. Yes.
在威伯福斯的传记电影中，他由本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇扮演。我不知道你有没有看过，《奇异恩典》。他由本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇扮演。实际上，那是少数几次——我的意思是，小皮特在《黑爵士》中被嘲笑过。
Pitt the Younger is the youngest. And Pitt is, he's seen as the incarnation of anti-corruption after what's been a pretty corrupt period in British politics, really going back to Walpole. He is modern he he creates a series of coalitions to fight napoleon he's very anti-jacobin anti-french revolution sort of patriotic yeah he he is and he's the guy behind you know who who essentially kind of inspires britain to fight against france um through the revolutionary period through the nappeljonic period um dies shortly after the battles of trafalgar and austerlitz but um he he is a very committed abolitionist so i think that yes that this is quite an important aspect of how prime ministers are seen at the moment is where they stood on issues of the empire and on slavery. Yeah, because this came up again and again on Twitter comments, didn't it? Again and again, yeah.
但小皮特——我的意思是，两个皮特在某种文化想象中都没有留下什么痕迹，不是吗？我的意思是，你在桑德兰街头随便拦住100个人，其中有多少人能向你讲述任何一个皮特的故事？所以，你知道，他们的重要性本该比实际情况更大。对我来说，小皮特能在锦标赛中走得这么远，其实是个小小的惊喜。我的意思是，也许这在某种程度上是一张反法选票，人们可能会说，你知道，也许他赢得了战争，万岁！他沾了纳尔逊的一点余辉，我猜。他还有一个著名的故事，是医生给他开波特酒，然后他就对它上瘾了——
So Pitt the Elder is definitely, I mean, he's a Mr. British Empire guy. And Pitt the Younger obviously holds it together by keeping Britain free from French invasion. But he is definitely on the side of angels when it comes to slavery. He's a friend of Wilberforce, big opponent of abolitionism. So perhaps that explains why, you know, that might be a part of why he went as far as he did.
是的，显然我昨天了解到，推特上的某个人告诉我，那个给他开波特酒的医生，他的儿子随后接替皮特成了首相——所以奥明顿勋爵（Lord Horningto）显然是在下一盘很大的棋。所以也许他会在下一年的世界杯中亮相，谁知道呢？好吧，我们已经完成了第一轮的四场比赛。
In the Wilberforce biopic, he's played by Benedict Cumberbatch. I don't know if you've seen it, Amazing Grace. He's played by Benedict Cumberbatch. And actually, that's one of the few times, I mean, Pitt the Younger was mocked in Blackadder.
中场休息回来后，我们将迎来最终的冠军。而且我们还有一些绝对的比赛巨擘，汤姆：劳埃德·乔治、沃波尔、阿斯奎斯，当然还有玛格丽特·撒切尔。所以中场休息后，请和我们一起关注这些重量级的竞争者。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦以及问答的必经之地，在问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及提前购买现场门票的特权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com，也就是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，我们当然在谈论首相世界杯。最终的赢家在这个半区的签表里吗？嗯，时间会证明一切。让我们从这个充满魅力的对决开始，汤姆·霍兰德——克莱门特·艾德礼对阵利物浦勋爵。在这场比赛中，你从一开始就看好谁？
But Pitt the Younger, I mean, both Pits have left very little mark on the kind of cultural imagination haven't they I mean most you stop 100 people in the street in in in sort of um in Sunderland and how many of them can tell you about either of the pits so you know that they they should loom larger than they do and it to me it was a slight surprise actually that pit younger got as far as he did in the tournament i mean maybe it's an anti-french vote to some extent people sort of said you know maybe he won he won wars hurrah he's sort of i'm asking a bit of nelson's reflected glory i suspect he he also was famously prescribed port by his doctor and and then became addicted to it um yeah and apparently i learned yes yesterday somebody on twitter told me that um the uh the the doctor who prescribed the port to him that his son
嗯，我——我支持克莱门特·艾德礼，我本以为他会赢，结果他也确实以81%的惊人优势获胜，我的意思是，那是最大的获胜优势。我想这可能是因为大多数人
then succeeded pitt as prime minister so lord ornington yeah was obviously playing the long game there so so maybe he'll feature in the next the next year's uh world cup who knows all right well we've done four of the first round matches. Coming up after the break, we have the eventual champion. And we have some absolute titans of the game, Tom. Lloyd George, Walpole, Asquith, and of course, Margaret Thatcher. So join us after the break for these colossal contenders. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz
根本不知道利物浦勋爵是谁。是的。包括我，因为我很尴尬地以为他是克里米亚战争期间的首相，而那当然是阿伯丁。是的。你基本上把城市搞混了，对吧？我是的。
gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisent is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history and we are of course talking about the prime minister's world cup um is the eventual winner on this side of the draw well time will tell let's start with um with this glamour tie tom holland um clement atley versus liverpool lord liverpool who did you fancy from the beginning in this one well well i i i i went for clement atley who i thought was going to win and indeed did win by the thumping margin of 81 i mean that was the largest margin of victory. And I think that's probably because most people
所以利物浦勋爵是个极其反动的人物，真的。他是拿破仑战争结束时期到19世纪20年代的人物。他担任首相的时间长得离谱。他是彼得卢惨案先生，对吧？所以这不会让他受到推特用户的任何欢迎。不，我有点——现在我看到这一点时，我在想，我们把他列为种子选手，纯粹是因为他任职时间长，而不是因为他有任何合理的获胜希望。
have no idea who Lord Liverpool is. Yes. Including me, because I rather embarrassingly thought that he was Prime Minister during the Crimean War, which was, of course, Aberdeen. Yeah. You basically got your cities mixed up, didn't you? I did.
你不是说过他是第一个穿裤子的首相吗？他是。他是第一个穿裤子（trousers）的首相。我认为这很合理。而且，他是唯一一位以其名字命名伦敦火车站的首相——利物浦街站。是这样吗？是的。这是一个非常棒的事实。
So Lord Liverpool is this sort of ultra-reactionary figure, really. He's the end of the Napoleonic Wars and into the 1920s. He's Prime Minister a ridiculously long time. And he's Mr Peterloo, isn't he? So that wouldn't make him popular with people on Twitter at all. No, I kind of, now that I look at that, I wonder whether we included him in the seeds purely on the basis of longevity rather than any reasonable prospect of victory.
是的。因为，当然，利物浦街站，你无法从利物浦街站去利物浦——它是以利物浦勋爵命名的。是的，显然还有彼得卢。所以他是这样的人，是的，从长远来看，人们永远只会知道他的一件事，那就是这个。所以我们应该顺便说一下——我意识到我们还没说过，他大概是在1812年至1827年在任。我的意思是，那是很长的一段时间，这么长的一段任期。这么长的时间。这么长的一段任期。但在一个稍微有点前民主的时代，你知道的，他是统治国家的相对贵族小集团的领导者，而他只是坚持了下来。支持他的论点是，他受到了许多非常著名的诗人的疯狂厌恶。所以拜伦、雪莱等等，他们对彼得卢和这一切作出了非常、非常、非常强烈的反应。但他们实际上从未把矛头对准利物浦。
Didn't you say that he was the first prime minister to wear trousers? He was. He was the first prime minister to wear trousers. I think that's reasonable. And also, he's the only prime minister to have a London railway station named after him, Liverpool Street. Is that right? Yeah. That's a very good fact.
他们总是针对卡苏利（Castlereagh），当时的外交大臣。我觉得利物浦勋爵有点缺乏个性。他是那种有点缺乏个性的首相，利物浦勋爵。他是那种有点缺乏个性的首相。我的意思是，从某种意义上说，艾德礼这场对决并不是那么糟糕的对决，因为他们在某些方面都不如他们政府中的某些角色那么知名。好吧，是的，那是很棒的专家评论。我喜欢那个。
Yes. Because, of course, Liverpool Street, you can't go to Liverpoolpool from liverpool street um it's named after lord liverpool yeah and obviously peterloo so he's one of these people yes in in the long run people will only ever know one thing about him and that will be so we should just say i realize that we haven't said he so he was probably 1812 to 1827 i mean that's a long such a long time such a long stretch. Such a long time. Such a long stretch. But obviously in a slightly pre-democratic era, you know, he's head of this sort of relatively aristocratic cabal that's running the country and he just sticks at it. And the argument in his favour is wildly unpopular with a lot of very famous poets. So Byron, Shelley and so on, who react very, very, very strongly against Peterloo and all that. But they never actually target Liverpool.
我真的很喜欢那个。那真的很好。你觉得我在这种事情上有职业前途吗？说到专家评论，我们现在转向比赛中绝对算得上明星级表现的一位选手，他没有闯过这一轮。那就是玛格丽特·撒切尔。是的。她曾是种子选手之一。她的对手是赫伯特·亨利·阿斯奎斯，他是1908年至1916年的首相。
They're always going after Castle Ray, who's foreign secretary at the time. I think it's slightly colourless, Lord Liverpool. He's one of these prime ministers who's slightly colourless, Lord Liverpool. He's one of these prime ministers who's slightly colourless. I mean, actually, in that sense, the Attlee match-up is not such a bad match-up because they both are less well-known in some ways than some of the characters in their governments. Yeah. Okay, yeah, that's great punditry there. I like that.
并且带领我们进入了第一次世界大战。带领我们进入了第一次世界大战，是的。所以阿斯奎斯，你知道，我喜欢阿斯奎斯。他是一个伟大的统帅。我非常喜欢阿斯奎斯。他赢得相当轻松，事实上，以59%的得票率击败了撒切尔。我们的制作人在这一切开始时对我说：“你知道的，如果撒切尔赢了，你得自己写剧本了。”
I really like that. That's really good. You think I've got a career in this kind of thing? And talking of punditry, we now move on to definitely one of the kind of star performers in the tournament who didn't go beyond this round. And that was Margaret Thatcher. Yeah. Who was one of the seeds. She was up against Herbert Henry Asquith, who was prime minister from, what is he, 1908 to 1916.
这暗示了一直以来都是他在写剧本，当然，你知道的，这其实是个有点存疑的问题。但……是的，她从来没有处于赢得比赛的危险之中，对吧？我的意思是，她从来没打算赢得这样一场比赛。这是一个关于玛格丽特·撒切尔的有趣现象，不仅仅是因为她具有分裂性，因为我认为政客按定义就是具有分裂性的，因为治理就是选择。你知道的，事实是这种分裂性持续了如此之久，以至于现在依然为许多人所定义。有那么几位其他的首相也是如此，我认为这非同寻常。而且我认为很大程度上是因为这个，汤姆，也许布莱尔也可能如此，但我认为撒切尔的情况更具情绪色彩。我认为情绪更加饱和。而且我个人认为，很大程度上是因为
And who led us into the First World War. Led us into the First World War, yeah. So Asquith, you know, I love Asquith. He's a great figure. I'm very fond of Asquith. He won pretty comfortably, actually, 59% beating Thatcher. And our producer had said to it me when this started you know if thatcher wins you're gonna have to write your own scripts um that
她是一个女人。而且我认为……我一直认为，很多情绪之所以如此饱和，正是因为她是一个女人，而且她被视为一个终结了某种男性化生活方式的女人。我认为这为它增添了许多情绪张力。因为特雷莎·梅就没有受到任何——我的意思是，人们几乎根本不记得她，对吧？不，人们真的不记得了。我的意思是，你已经可以说，你知道的，特雷莎·梅在历史上将只是一个脚注，
that suggests that he always writes the scripts which of course you know that's a bit of a kind of a moot point um but uh yeah she was never in danger winning the tournament was she i mean she was never going to win a tournament like this um and it's an interesting thing with margaret thatcher it's not just that she's divisive because i think to be a politician by definition is to be divisive because to govern is to choose and you know it's the fact that she the divisiveness has lingered so long and now defines her for a lot of people and there are a few other prime ministers of whom that's true i think and it's extraordinary and i think a lot of that tom perhaps blair possibly but i think it's more charged with thatcher i think it's much more charged and i think personally i think a lot of it is because
就像戈登·布朗一样，或者像詹姆斯·卡拉汉，或者亚历克·道格拉斯-休姆爵士。你知道有些首相——你知道爱德华·希思只当了三年半的首相，但他做了很多事，而且他是“欧洲先生”。欧洲是他的核心主题，这
she's a woman and i think um i've always thought that a lot of it is very charged because of because she's a woman and because she's seen as a woman who closed down a particular masculine way of life. And I think that adds a lot of the charge to it. Because Theresa May isn't regarded with any... I mean, people barely remember her at all, do they? No, people don't really remember. I mean, already you can sort of say, you know, that Theresa May will be a bit of a footnote in history,
定义了他。有什么能定义梅夫人呢？我的意思是，未能实现脱欧。未能实现脱欧，未能达成一致……是的，是的，好吧。所以撒切尔夫人输了。阿斯奎斯——当然，一个和你一样出自贝利奥尔学院的人。是的，就像我一样。贝利奥尔学院之人的优越感。所以你当时是在支持他吗？我希望他能——我……我确实喜欢看到阿斯奎斯走得远，因为我认为他在第一次世界大战中被劳埃德·乔治狠狠地坑了。当然，阿斯奎斯——阿斯奎斯是一个极其美妙的人物，你知道的，当第一次世界大战爆发时，他正忙着纠缠他女儿的
as Gordon Brown is actually or as James Callaghan is or Sir Alec Douglas Hume. You know there are some Prime Ministers, you know Ted Heath was only Prime Minister for three and a half years but he did a lot and he was Mr Europe. Europe was his thing and that
最好朋友维妮西亚·斯坦利（Venetia Stanley），并不断给她写信。事实上，有一个极其滑稽的时刻，就在第一次世界大战爆发前大约一周。他写信给维妮西亚·斯坦利——基本上，她比他年轻大约25岁左右——说：“这是我经历过的最可怕的折磨。我不得不放弃在乡间别墅周末去见你的计划，因为我必须处理这场该死的第一世界大战。”
defined him. What's going to define Mrs May? I mean failing to get Brexit. Failing to get brexit failing together yeah yeah okay so so mrs satcher lost um asquith uh of course a baliel man like yourself yeah like myself the superiority of a baliel man so were you were you backing him again i wanted him to well i um i i do like to see asquith going far because i think he was utterly shafted by lloyd george in the first world war and of course asquith asquith is this fantastic character you know he's basically in the first world breaks out he's busy bothering his daughter's
定义了她。什么将定义梅夫人？我是说未能实现脱欧。未能实现脱欧未能达成一致是的是的好的所以所以撒切尔夫人失去了嗯阿斯奎斯呃当然像你这样贝利奥尔学院的人是的像我这样贝利奥尔学院的人的优越性所以你当时在支持他吗我希望他能嗯我我我确实喜欢看阿斯奎斯走得远因为我认为他在第一次世界大战中被劳埃德·乔治狠狠地坑了当然阿斯奎斯阿斯奎斯是个如此了不起的人物你知道当第一次世界大战爆发时他正忙着纠缠他女儿的
best friend venetia stanley and sending her these endless letters in fact there's a hilarious moment about a week before the first world breaks out out. He writes to Venetia Stanley, who's basically, what is he, about 25 years his junior or something, and says this is the most awful torment I've ever known. I have to give up coming to see you at Country House weekend because I've got to deal with this bloody First World War.
最好的朋友威尼西亚·斯坦利并给她写了无数的信事实上在第一次世界大战爆发前大约一周有一个非常搞笑的时刻。他写信给威尼西亚·斯坦利她基本上比他小二十五岁左右或者差不多这样并且说这是我经历过的最可怕的折磨。我不得不放弃周末去乡村别墅看你的计划因为我得处理这该死的第一次世界大战。
And there's a lot of this sort of stuff. During one of the battles of the Western Front, he's spotted reading a book in the Athenaeum while having his hair cut. And there's all this sort of misbehaviour. Bono Law, the Conservative leader, when they went into coalition, went round to talk to Asquith and he was kind of playing bridge with three young ladies. That's kind of what I i mean you you wouldn't think that this is the guy to to beat a a heavyweight champion like thatcher but um clearly is it
诸如此类的事情还有很多。在西线战役期间，有人发现他在理发的时候坐在雅典娜神庙里看书。还有各种各样的恶作剧。保守党领袖博纳·劳在组建联合政府时去拜访阿斯奎斯，当时阿斯奎斯正和三位年轻女性打桥牌。我的意思是，你不会觉得这家伙能击败像撒切尔这样的重量级拳王，但显然他做到了。
yeah clearly king reading classic books and having your hair cut during battles is obviously the way to go but i quite like the idea that somebody who sits around reading classic books beat someone who never did um anyway let's move on so the next match was um so robert walpole the first prime minister against uh peel uh and walpole won that 64 percent no he didn't he lost it he lost it peel i'm sorry yes yes sorry peel one yeah peel one so walpole was seeded and i guess that you seeded him because he i mean he's the first prime minister so he's the beginning of the 18th century um obviously a titanic figure yeah but i guess that perhaps people don't do people remember peel better than they remember walpole i mean i think people remember peelel better than they remember Walpole? I mean, I think people remember Peel.
是的，显然国王在战斗中读经典书籍和理发显然是正确的方法，但我很喜欢这样一个想法，即一个坐着读经典书籍的人击败了一个从未读过经典书籍的人。不管怎样，我们继续吧。所以下一场比赛是——罗伯特·沃波尔，第一任首相，对阵皮尔。沃波尔以64%的得票率获胜——不，他没有，他输了，他输了。皮尔，对不起，是的，是的，对不起，皮尔赢了，是的，皮尔赢了。所以沃波尔是种子选手，我猜你把他列为种子选手是因为他是第一任首相，所以他是18世纪初的人，显然是一个巨大的人物。是的，但我猜也许人们对皮尔的记忆比对沃波尔的记忆更深刻？我的意思是，我认为人们对皮尔的记忆比对沃波尔的记忆更深刻？我的意思是，我认为人们记得皮尔。
Some people have done Peel at school other than the Corn Laws, the repeal of the Corn Laws. So basically when Peel, the Corn Laws were a hugely sort of beloved pillar of Tory ideology, protecting domestic farmers and keeping prices of food high and uh peel repeals the corn laws um basically committing political suicide because he thinks that people in the cities should get cheap food from abroad and also this is against the the backdrop of the uh of famine in ireland as well isn't it yeah and course, the other thing that he's... Exactly. And of course, the other thing he's remembered for
除了《谷物法》和废除《谷物法》之外，有些人还在学校里学过皮尔。所以基本上当皮尔——《谷物法》曾是托利党意识形态中广受喜爱的支柱，保护国内农民并维持高昂的食物价格——皮尔废除了《谷物法》，这基本上等于政治自杀，因为他认为城市居民应该从国外得到便宜的食物，而且这也是以爱尔兰饥荒为背景的，对吧？是的，当然，他被记住的另一件事是……没错。当然，他被记住的另一件事是
is the police. So, Bobbies, you know, the Metropolitan Police. So Peel has two big things sort of in his favour that people remember. Now, Walpole, to me, Walpole should be a semi-finalist. I mean, there's no doubt in my mind that Walpole is in the top four because he founded the Office of Prime Minister
警察。也就是“博比”（Bobbies），你知道的，伦敦警察厅。所以皮尔有两个对他的有利之处是人们能记住的。现在，对我和沃波尔来说，沃波尔应该是一个半决赛选手。我的意思是，毫无疑问沃波尔在前四名中，因为他创立了首相办公室
at the beginning of the kind of hanoverian succession um walpole establishes stability he's prime minister for 21 years but he's a massive crook isn't he he is a crook but i mean who isn't a crook in 18th century politics i mean that's just a sort of that's a that's a ludicrous allegation to me even even by the standards of the early 18th century, he's regarded as a crook. But I think there's much... I mean, he keeps us out of lots of foreign wars.
在汉诺威王朝初期，沃波尔确立了稳定性，他担任了21年的首相，但他是个超级大骗子，不是吗？他是个骗子，但我的意思是，18世纪政治中谁不是骗子？我的意思是，这对我来说简直是一个荒谬的指控，即使按照18世纪早期的标准，他也被视为一个骗子。但我认为还有很多……我的意思是，他让我们免于许多对外战争。
He has... You know, Britain is extremely stable, you know, by comparison to what's come before. I mean, you think what's come... If you're becoming prime minister in 1721, it's a new office. You've just got this German monarch over. It's against the backdrop...
他拥有……你知道的，与过去相比，英国极其稳定。我的意思是，你想想过去……如果你在1721年成为首相，这是一个新职位。你刚刚迎来了这位德国君主。这是在……的背景下
To whom you're speaking in Latin. Yes, extraordinary, extraordinary. And against the backdrop of pretty much in living memory, you've had the Glorious Revolution, one king being kicked out. You have the Civil War lurking behind all that. And you have the rise of France as the great superpower and all this. And Walpole presides over this sort of this this golden age in some ways um for the new united kingdom you know it's in
你在跟他用拉丁语对话。是的，太不可思议了，太不可思议了。而且背景是，在有生之年，你经历过了光荣革命，一个国王被赶下台。所有这一切背后潜藏着内战。而且你看到了法国作为超级大国的崛起以及所有这一切。在某种程度上，沃波尔主持了新联合王国的这个黄金时代，你知道的，这是在
great britain is a new country formed in 1707 and all of that is a is a tremendous achievement and sure he lined his pockets but they all did and you know i think he should i think he should be in the top i think he should be two or three to be honest in british prime so he's but he's portrayed as um howieman in in the beggars opera and he said cross about that that he then brings in the what is it the lord chamberlain censoring plays yeah i don't mind that i'm quite authoritarian as you know, so. I don't know. He enshrines wiggishness as the absolute governing creed of 18th century Britain. And he defines British politics in the 18th century.
大不列颠是1707年成立的一个新国家，所有这些都是巨大的成就。当然，他捞了自己的腰包，但他们都这么做。你知道，我认为他应该，我认为他应该在前列，老实说，在英国首相中他应该排在第二或第三位。所以他被描绘成《乞丐歌剧》中的大坏蛋，对此他很不高兴，以至于他随后引入了——是什么来着——宫廷内侍大臣来审查戏剧？是的，我不介意这个，如你所知，我相当专制，所以。我不知道。他将辉格党主义奉为18世纪英国的绝对统治信条。他定义了18世纪的英国政治。
He had beautiful porcelain, and I've seen his porcelain. Do you know where I saw it? Do you know where it is? I can't possibly imagine. It's in the Hermitage in St. petersburg rick it's rubber war poles yeah so so um he had an amazing art collection in howton hall in norfolk um and then it all got sold to uh catherine the great that's a very interesting fact very interesting and i think it went back to howton hall um a couple of years ago and i spent all the time it was there i was thinking i must go and see it i must go and see it and then i
他有漂亮的瓷器，我见过他的瓷器。你知道我在哪里看到的吗？你知道它在哪里吗？我简直无法想象。它在圣彼得堡的冬宫，瑞克。那是罗伯特·沃波尔的，是的。所以，他拥有诺福克霍顿厅的惊人艺术收藏，然后这一切都被卖给了叶卡捷琳娜大帝。这是一个非常有趣的事实，非常有趣。我想它在几年前回到了霍顿厅，我在它那里的所有时间里都在想，我一定要去看看，我一定要去看看，然后我
completely forgot to go and see it so an opportunity wasted but i had seen it in the hermitage so that was what a great story there from uh from tv um we've got punditry robert peel had a staffordshire accent that's another good yeah so peel is one of the last prime ministers, really, for a very long time, to have a non-RP accent. And there's a point at which, obviously, all prime ministers after that are going to public school, and they're all speaking the same way. But he's got a regional accent. Peel went to Harrow, where he was friends with Byron.
完全忘记去看了，所以这是一个浪费的机会。但我曾在冬宫见过它，所以这是蒂姆（Tv）讲的一个非常棒的故事。我们有专家点评：罗伯特·皮尔有斯塔福德郡口音。这也是一个好点——皮尔是相当长一段时间内，极少数带有非RP（皇室标准发音）口音的首相之一。在某个时候，显然后来的所有首相都去公学上学，他们的口音都一样。但他有地方口音。皮尔曾就读于哈罗公学，在那里他和拜伦是朋友。
Yeah, but obviously he kept his... So obviously he didn't pick it up. And then he gives the Tamworth Manifesto, doesn't he? Which is the first political manifesto in British history. So somebody, we were talking about Gladstone earlier, and we'll come back to Gladstone in another podcast, but somebody was sharing a clip online. There's a recording of Gladstone speaking
是的，但显然他保留了……所以显然他没有染上那种口音。然后他发表了《塔姆沃思宣言》，对吧？这是英国历史上第一份政治宣言。所以有人——我们之前谈到了格莱斯顿，我们会在另一期播客中再次谈到格莱斯顿——但有人在网上分享了一个片段。有一段格莱斯顿演讲的录音
and there's this claim that Gladstone spoke with a Liverpool accent and he doesn't. He sounds nothing like, you know, Ricky Tomlins. Imagine no possessions. Yes. Yeah. Okay. So that's Walpole and Peel.
有人声称格莱斯顿带有利物浦口音，但他根本没有。他听起来一点也不像里奇·汤姆林斯（Ricky Tomlinson）。想象一无所有。是的。好的。这就是沃波尔和皮尔。
And then the final one was Lloyd George against Harold Wilson. You've already been reading about Harold Wilson and given away the result. So no shot. Lloyd George won that 60%. Maybe come to Lloyd George when we talk about the quarterfinals. Let's do Wilson. Let's do Wilson. Yeah, let's do Wilson.
最后一场是劳埃德·乔治对阵哈罗德·威尔逊。你已经读过关于哈罗德·威尔逊的书并把结果剧透了。所以毫无悬念。劳埃德·乔治以60%的得票率获胜。也许当我们谈到四分之一决赛时再讲劳埃德·乔治。我们讲威尔逊吧。我们讲威尔逊。是的，我们讲威尔逊。
So some people love Wilson, don't they? Some people love Wilson. I've written a lot about Harold Wilson. I've basically written hundreds of thousands of words about Harold Wilson. And I always think he would be a great person to have as your next-door neighbour. Why's that? He's a nice guy. He'd lend you his lawnmower. His Mac.
有些人很喜欢威尔逊，对吧？有些人很喜欢威尔逊。我写过很多关于哈罗德·威尔逊的文章。我基本上写了成千上万关于哈罗德·威尔逊的字。我一直认为他会是一个很好的邻居。为什么这么说？他人很好。他会把割草机借给你。他的Mac。
His good company. You know, you could go round and he'd get out the brandy bottle. He has a great knowledge. He'd be great on this podcast, actually, because he had a great knowledge of minutiae. He and Roy Jenkins, when Roy Jenkins was a chancellor, they bonded over their knowledge of railway timetables, for which they were both enthusiasts he was very young wasn't he when he became he was about 10 or something when he became yeah when he became
他是个很好的陪伴。你知道的，你可以去他家，他会拿出一瓶白兰地。他知识渊博。其实他在这个播客里会表现得很棒，因为他对细节有着极好的了解。他和罗伊·詹金斯——当罗伊·詹金斯担任财政大臣时——他们因对铁路时刻表的共同了解而结下情谊，他们俩都是这方面的狂热爱好者。他当选时很年轻，对吧？当他成为——当他大约10岁左右的时候，当他成为——是的，当他成为
president of the board of trade that's right yeah and he had this terrible mustache which he grew in the 1940s to make himself appear um to make himself appear more mature he had got supposedly the best degree in economics or something, the best mark in economics that Oxford had ever seen when he was a – and he was at Oxford in the 30s, I think it's the 30s, at a time when everybody else was going to sort of communist meetings and cocktail parties, and Wilson was asked to go to one of these, and he said, no, thank you very much.
贸易委员会主席，对，是的。他留着这副糟糕的胡子，这是他在20世纪40年代留的，为了让自己看起来——为了让自己显得更成熟。据说他获得了牛津大学有史以来最好的经济学学位或类似的东西，经济学最高分——当他是——他在30年代在牛津，我想是30年代，当时其他所有人都去参加诸如共产主义会议和鸡尾酒会之类的活动，而威尔逊被邀请去参加其中一个时，他说，不，非常感谢。
I came here to work and uh basically man after your own heart and all the yes exactly and all this sort of a lot of his labor um colleagues actually looked down on him because they saw him as too middle brow he read agatha christie he played golf he ate tin salmon rather than smoked um he had these sort of very humdrum habits, which, of course, endeared him hugely to ordinary voters because people saw in Wilson somebody like themselves. I always think Wilson is a great model for the Labour Party. You know, if you pick somebody like Wilson,
我是来工作的，呃，基本上是个合你心意的人，所有的——是的，正好，诸如此类的。他的许多工党同事其实看不起他，因为他们认为他太中庸了。他读阿加莎·克里斯蒂，他打高尔夫球，他吃罐头三文鱼而不是熏鱼。他有着这些非常平淡乏味的习惯，当然，这让他极大地赢得了普通选民的喜爱，因为人们在威尔逊身上看到了和自己一样的人。我一直认为威尔逊是工党的一个伟大模范。你知道，如果你挑选像威尔逊这样的人，
I mean, he's not that dissimilar from Attlee. Sort of small C conservative, patriotic, ordinary. He makes a virtue of his own ordinariness and he he goes out of his way to say it's the Tories who are extraordinary because they're rich and spoiled and and I'm just like you I'm not you know he didn't make a great point of ideology so when he commissioned Philip Ziegler the biographer of Mountbatten to be his um to be his authorized biographer Ziegler said to him you know i'd love to do it but there's one problem i i'm not a socialist and wilson said oh don't worry neither am i
我的意思是，他和艾利其实没那么大区别。有点小c的保守派，爱国，普通。他把自己的平庸引以为傲，并且特意指出，是保守党人非同寻常，因为他们富有、被宠坏了，而我就像你一样，我不是——你知道，他并没有大肆宣扬意识形态。所以当他委任蒙巴顿的传记作家菲利普·齐格勒（Philip Ziegler）担任他的官方传记作家时，齐格勒对他说：“你知道，我很乐意做这件事，但有一个问题，我不是社会主义者。”威尔逊说：“哦，别担心，我也不是。”
and that sort of thing it's basically a lot of his own activists held against him i think that kind of thing endeared him to to ordinary voters okay i've got a question for you which is um flagging up a podcast we're going to do on we're going out on thursday with ben mcintyre about the history of espionage and spying um wilson thought that he was being bugged by mi5 didn't he he did particularly really it's really really unclear so wilson does in his second time in office which is pretty shabby and i would say it's probably the worst period of prime ministerial leadership in our lifetimes uh 74 to 76 he does seem to have got very very paranoid he thought he was being bugged by the south africans by boss the south african spy agency and he also thinks you know there's lots of spy agency was called boss yeah unbelievably that's
诸如此类的事情——基本上他的许多激进主义者因此对他心存芥蒂。我认为这种事情让他赢得了普通选民的喜爱。好吧，我有一个问题要问你，那就是关于我们周四将要发布的、由本·麦金太尔（Ben Macintyre）主讲的关于间谍和情报历史的播客。威尔逊认为他的办公室被军情五处（MI5）窃听了，对吧？他是这么认为的，尤其是——其实这非常非常不清楚。所以威尔逊在第二个任期内——这一时期相当糟糕，我认为这可能是我们有生之年中首相领导力最糟糕的时期，从74年到76年——他似乎变得非常非常偏执。他认为自己被南非人窃听了，被南非间谍机构BOSS窃听了。他还认为，你知道，有很多间谍机构被称为BOSS。是的，难以置信，那是
brilliant brilliant bureau of state, I think it is. Goodness, I've learned something. And so the stories, people like Shirley Williams tell these stories. They say he would take them into the dining room or the cabinet room, and he'd point to a picture of Gladstone, funnily enough, and he'd point to Gladstone, and he'd say, that portrait is bugged. They're watching me through Gladstone,
太棒了，国家安全局（Bureau of State），我想是这样。天哪，我学到了新东西。所以这些故事，像雪莉·威廉姆斯（Shirley Williams）这样的人会讲这些故事。他们说他会把他们带到餐厅或内阁会议室，说来也巧，他会指着一张格莱斯顿的照片，他会指着格莱斯顿说，那张肖像被窃听了。他们正在通过格莱斯顿监视我，
or they're listening to me through Gladstone. Or he'd take people into the toilets and say, we can only talk here, and he'd put on the taps, all this sort of stuff. I mean, this actually, this genuinely happened. Now, some of his ministers thought this was demented. And he did have, he had dementia, didn't he, while he was in office? Well, it's unclear, but possibly in the final months. Certainly his mind, his memory was not what it was. And he said as much to his aides, to Joe Haynes and Bernard Donoghue,
或者他们通过格莱斯顿在听我说话。或者他会把人带到厕所里说，我们只能在这里谈话，然后他会打开水龙头，诸如此类的。我的意思是，这实际上——这确实发生了。现在，他的一些部长认为这简直是精神错乱。他在任期间确实患上了痴呆症，不是吗？嗯，这还不清楚，但可能在最后的几个月里确实如此。当然，他的大脑和记忆力已经不如从前了。他曾对他的助手乔·海恩斯（Joe Haynes）和伯纳德·多诺休（Bernard Donoughue）这样说过
who were his closest aides, he would say, I don't really have anything to say. I can't remember about this. You know, I'm not what I was. So it's possible. Were they systematically bugging him? I think not. But I think there were agents within it.
他们是他最亲密的助手，他会说，我真的没什么好说的。我不记得这个了。你知道的，我不如以前了。所以这是可能的。他们是在系统性地窃听他吗？我认为没有。但我认为里面有一些特工。
I mean, MI5 was a pretty ramshackle, shabby, I mean, very Le Carre-like, actually, in the 70s. And there were people like Peter Wright, who wrote the book Spycatcher, who were kind of paranoid, you know, slightly Daily Express-ish, kind of. They thought Wilson was a red, and they were kind of going around saying,
我的意思是，军情五处在70年代是一个相当破烂不堪、寒酸的机构，非常具有勒卡雷（Le Carre）的风格。当时有一些像彼得·赖特（Peter Wright）这样的人，他写了《捕鸟者》（Spycatcher）这本书，他们有点偏执，你知道的，有点《每日快报》的风格。他们认为威尔逊是个“红皮”，到处说
I mean, when Ted Heath was asked about this, Ted Heath said, he said, basically basically the people in mi5 are so mad that when they see somebody on the tube reading the daily mirror they say he must be a communist we must we must have him followed so clearly across the political spectrum there was a sense that mi5 was slightly out of control um so wilson was probably on to to something so MI5 will be pleased that Wilson was knocked out, losing 60% to Lloyd George. And I think that wraps up the group matches. Okay.
我的意思是，当特德·希斯（Ted Heath）被问及此事时，特德·希斯说，他基本上说——军情五处的人实在是疯了，当他们在伦敦地铁上看到有人在读《每日镜报》时，他们就会说“他一定是个共产党人，我们必须派人跟踪他”。所以很明显，在整个政治光谱中，人们都觉得军情五处有点失控，所以威尔逊可能确实察觉到了什么。因此，军情五处会对威尔逊被淘汰感到高兴，他以60%对40%输给了劳埃德·乔治。我想这就总结了小组赛。好吧。
So we're left with the quarterfinals, which was... Extraordinary drama in the quarterfinals. So the quarterfinals are Peel against Pitt the Younger, Lloyd George against Attlee, Disraeli against gladstone churchill against asquith we then had the semifinals and then of course the final um and we will go through those various matches we will look at the titans who were playing in those rounds um close-up analysis all the kind of sports punditry that you'd expect from someone like Dominic. And we will be putting that into a second Prime Ministerial World Cup podcast, which will be going out tomorrow.
所以我们迎来了四分之一决赛，也就是——四分之一决赛中出现了非凡的戏剧性场面。所以四分之一决赛是皮尔对阵小皮特，劳埃德·乔治对阵艾德礼，迪斯雷利对阵格莱斯顿，丘吉尔对阵阿斯奎斯，然后我们进行了半决赛，当然还有决赛——我们将回顾这些不同的比赛，我们将看看在这些轮次中比赛的巨头们——近距离分析所有你对多米尼克（Dominic）这样的人所期望的体育专家点评。我们将把这些内容放入第二期首相世界杯播客中，该播客将于明天发布。
So that is it from us for now. We will follow through this thrilling sporting contest in tomorrow's podcast. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
这就是我们目前的全部内容。我们将在明天的播客中继续关注这场惊心动魄的体育竞赛。再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听独家分集、提前抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是 restishistorypod.com。那是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。